muy bien cuando introdujimos el sistema
endocrino mencionamos que las hormonas
se podían clasificar según su función
hablamos de la función auto crin a la
función para crina y la función
endocrina pero tal vez incluso más
importante las hormonas se pueden
clasificar por su estructura y decimos
que es más importante porque la
estructura de la hormona realmente
determina cómo funciona esto es de lo
que quiero que hablemos en este vídeo
los tipos de hormonas más importantes
la primera categoría de hormonas
importantes son las proteínas y los
polipéptidos vamos a recordar que las
proteínas y los polipéptidos están
hechos de aminoácidos y estos
aminoácidos están unidos entre sí con
enlaces peptídicos varios enlaces
peptídicos se juntan para formar un
polipéptidos
o una proteína y éstos forman la mayoría
de las hormonas de nuestro cuerpo estas
hormonas pueden variar de pequeñas a
grandes así que vamos a dar un ejemplo
de qué significa esto
imaginemos tres aminoácidos unidos entre
ellos eso sería un pequeño polipéptido
en tres aminoácidos tenemos un puñado de
átomos tal vez unos veinte de ellos y
como marco de referencia en una célula
de tu cuerpo en una sola tenemos
alrededor de un billón de átomos y hay
cerca de 100 billones de células en tu
cuerpo es decir estamos hablando de
cosas muy muy pequeñas que pueden variar
desde estas pequeñas colecciones de
aminoácidos hasta cientos y cientos de
aminoácidos pueden hacerse muy grandes
pero el punto de quiebre empieza
alrededor de los 100
y ahí cambiamos el nombre de paul y
peptídicos a proteínas y como todas las
proteínas de tu cuerpo que serán
decretadas los polis peptídicos y las
proteínas se crean en el retículo
endoplasmático rugoso de la célula
r r
y farc del retículo endoplasmático
rugoso al aparato de golgi y del aparato
de golgi se empaquetarán en vesículas
que finalmente pueden ser excretadas por
la célula y dado que las proteínas y los
polis peptídicos están hechos de
aminoácidos comúnmente están cargados lo
que los hace solubles al agua pero eso
también hace que les sea difícil cruzar
las membranas celulares
entonces los receptores normalmente se
ubican sobre la superficie de la célula
y dado que los receptores están
localizados sobre la superficie de la
célula y que estas proteínas y hormonas
poli peptídicas no pueden viajar hacia
adentro de la célula lo que hacen es
iniciar un efecto cascada de segundos
mensajeros dentro de la célula en un
vídeo futuro estudiaremos cómo funciona
esta cascada de señalización es usando
segundos mensajeros pero la idea general
es que cuando estas hormonas
y poli peptídicas se enlazan a la
superficie de la célula e inician una
respuesta dentro de ella y nos referimos
a esto como un sistema de segundo
mensajero para ahorrarnos un poco de
tiempo dibuje un ejemplo de una hormona
poli peptídica que voy a traer por aquí
lo que debemos analizar en este dibujo
es donde se encuentran los enlaces
peptídicos ya que estos enlaces
peptídicos reúnen esta categoría y la
unificada
justo entre el carbono y el nitrógeno
por aquí y el carbono y el nitrógeno por
acá tenemos a los enlaces peptídicos a
los que nos referimos son unos enlaces
de carbono en nitrógeno
pueden ser pequeños o grandes pero estos
enlaces de aminoácidos llamados
proteínas o poli peptídicos se usan como
mensajes químicos para transmitir
señales de efectos en el cuerpo y un
ejemplo es la insulina la insulina es
una hormona relativamente grande es una
hormona proteica
muy bien esta es nuestra primera clase
ahora el segundo tipo de hormona
importante son los esteroides y cuando
escuchamos la palabra esteroides lo
primero que nos viene a la mente son un
montón de atletas metiéndose en
problemas con sus respectivos comités
reguladores pero realmente los
esteroides son uno de los tipos de
hormonas más importantes que usamos en
nuestro cuerpo para la comunicación
interna por lo tanto hay muchos
esteroides en tu cuerpo los esteroides
vienen de los lípidos y el lípido más
importante de donde vienen es el
colesterol dado que vienen del
colesterol los esteroides tienen una
estructura en particular que todos
comparten así que he dibujado un ejemplo
de una hormona esteroide a que voy a
traer por aquí
este es un típico esqueleto de un
esteroide puedes ver que tenemos una
estructura de cuatro anillos y estos
anillos están hechos de átomos de
carbono tenemos tres anillos de
ciclohexano o un anillo de seis átomos
de carbono y un anillo de ciclo pentano
y los vamos a etiquetar como a b c y d
y con esta estructura característica
tiene una forma única de señalización
celular a diferencia de las proteínas y
los polipéptidos cuyos receptores están
en la superficie de la célula los
esteroides dado que están hechos de
lípidos pasan de manera más fácil a
través de la membrana celular y por lo
tanto sus receptores están dentro de la
célula los esteroides hacen todo el
camino hacia dentro de la célula para
activar los receptores como primeros
mensajeros son ellos quienes hacen la
señalización a menudo sus receptores
están localizados ya sea en el
citoplasma o en el núcleo pero los
esteroides entran y su efecto llega
hasta el nivel de transcripción y
traducción de las proteínas entonces los
primeros mensajeros se dirigen al
interior de la célula y efectúan cambios
que resultan en la transcripción y
traducción de nuevas proteínas y nuevos
productos dentro de la célula en un
futuro
un vídeo de como los esteroides afectan
a la célula por ahora quiero que
pensemos en los esteroides como una de
las hormonas más importantes en nuestro
cuerpo y no solo como un medio de los
atletas para sacar ventaja en las
competencias algunos ejemplos de grandes
esteroides en el cuerpo son aquellos que
vienen de la corteza suprarrenal como el
cortisol y la aldosterona o las hormonas
que vienen de las gónadas como las
hormonas sexuales testosterona estrógeno
y progesterona entonces tenemos a los
esteroides y las proteínas y los poli
peptídicos y el tercer tipo más
importante de hormonas por su estructura
son los derivados de la tirosina los
derivados de la tirosina vienen del
aminoácido tirosina como mencionamos
anteriormente las hormonas proteicas y
poli peptídicas están hechas de
aminoácidos así que seguramente te
preguntarás por qué
es otra categoría importante si también
están hechos de aminoácidos lo que hace
a esta categoría muy especial es primero
que están hechos de un aminoácido
entonces tenemos un aminoácido la
tirosina que es manipulada para hacer
estas hormonas y segundo es que estas
hormonas derivadas de la tirosina son
capaces de actuar a veces como proteínas
y paul y peptídicos ya veces como
esteroides es por ello que las
estudiaremos como una clase
independiente
un ejemplo de derivados de la tirosina
en el cuerpo son las hormonas que vienen
de la glándula tiroides como t3 y t4
trillo tirolina y tiroxina que estimulan
el metabolismo estos derivados de la
tirosina actúan de manera similar que
los esteroides otro ejemplo de derivados
de la tirosina son las catecolaminas las
catecolaminas son las hormonas que se
producen en la médula renal y que están
involucradas en la respuesta corporal de
lucha o huida como la epinefrina o la
norepinefrina y estos derivados de la
tirosina actúan de manera similar a los
pep típicos vinculándose con el exterior
de la célula y liberando estos segundos
mensajeros en el interior de la célula
entonces las hormonas de la tiroides que
son derivados de la tirosina actúan como
esteroides mientras que las
catecolaminas que también son derivados
de la tirosina actúan como proteínas y
poli peptídicos es importante recordar
que forman su propia categoría ya que
todas derivan del aminoácido tirosina
y dado que dibujamos las proteínas y
poli peptídicos y los esteroides vamos a
dibujar también cómo se ve una tirosina
esta es la tirosina este es el
aminoácido de las que se derivan estas
clases de hormonas sé que es difícil
enseñar de manera divertida estos tipos
de hormonas pero espero que al menos
podamos sorprendernos un poco sobre el
hecho de que la estructura de las
hormonas dicta casi todo lo que pensamos
o hacemos desde el miedo el hambre las
ganas de orinar hasta dar a luz a bebés
las hormonas son responsables de la
señalización de todas las respuestas al
mundo que nos rodea